un homme âgé une moitié entier dans sa
musique ont-ils à sa parole entier dans
sa façon de penser on a été complice
depuis le début de l'aventuré avec boca
et même avant puisque nous sommes ici du
même quartier où ses jambes au final
donc on est et on s'est rencontré de
nouveau la musique la voiture musique
bourret a commencé en 1999 avec l'as
monaco catchy et puis s'est achevée
malause manière parce que il ya encore
des titres qu'on devait faire avec
georges
c'est un grand avec une grande
simplicité mais c'était un homme un
homme un homme tel qu'il est avec ses
défauts avec son franc parler surtout
ceux qui venaient georges le connais
secteur fera parler avec sa façon d'être
il push jeudi à parce que où il est pour
appuyer ses serres et puis jusqu'au bout
avec ses amis jusqu'au bout avec ses
amis ça c'était aux folles